this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happened you bad
[__] it's Monday the 27th of
March the joint is brought to you by
DraftKings listen the biggest tournament
in college basketball is heating up this
is it this is the big weekend and
there's still time to place a bet on
DraftKings Sportsbook show your team
loyalty by putting your money where your
[__] mouth is every weekend tell me
about what college you went to here's
your spot here's your chance new
customers I'll tell you what you can
make a five dollar pregame pregame
moneyline bet and score 150 in bonus
bets if your team wins who's better than
you nobody I'm looking at UConn with
Danny Hurley to Jack them all up this
weekend but listen DraftKings is
bringing you parlays and out boost for
the rest of the tournament so be sure to
check the app every day to see what they
have in store and the party starts today
do me a favor let's have some [__]
fun download the DraftKings Sportsbook
app and sign up with code Joey this is
the best week in sports as far as I'm
concerned new customers can bet five
dollars on any pregame money line and
get a hundred thousand bonus bets when
your team wins only on DraftKings
Sportsbook with Coach Joey minimum age
and eligibility restrictions apply see
show notes for details the joint is also
sponsored by Blue chew it's true what
they say confidence can make up for a
multitude of sins so make sure you got
that confidence when and where it counts
Bluetooth is an online service that
delivers Ed medicine straight to your
door when I say Ed I mean erectile
dysfunction and when I mean erectile
dysfunction I'm talking about that dick
but don't let it get you down it's a
Monday with the same active ingredients
as Viagra Cialis and Levitra at the
fraction of the cost this is the best
deal you'll get on a Monday morning from
Uncle Joe you know why because Bluetooth
is [__] tremendous so do me a favor
Bluetooth will make you will make sure
you're prepared when it's time to play
chopsticks with your dick Bluetooth
wants to help you have better sex
Discovery options at
bluetooth.com chew it and do it Jack
they've got a special deal for Uncle
Joy's joint listeners when you try
Bluetooth you're going to get it for
free when you use promo code Joey at
checkout that's j-o-e-y for free you're
just gonna pay five dollars for shipping
that's bluetooth.com promo code Joey to
receive your first month free who's
better than you nobody so visit
bluetooth.com for more important details
and important safety information and I
want to thank Bluetooth for sponsoring
the podcast today let's get this body's
God it's Monday morning we got [__] to
talk about
it
check one two welcome to Uncle Joey's
Joy
[Music]
foreign
[__] it's Monday the 27th of
March the last goddamn week Uncle Joey's
joined here for some [__] Monday
motivation I'm trying not to curse in
the first five minutes but it don't
matter YouTube still gives me the hook
so who cares I gotta be me it's a
beautiful [__] day to be a life alive
uh the sun's out it's been [__] warm
I guess
I guess I was wrong guys I guess uh
climate change is [__] real I'm happy
political people are having meetings
about climate change and at war with
Scientists listen
all I can tell you is it's three years
here
February has been [__] light I
honestly thought
just from living that this week this
month this this winter would be a
[__] horrible winter from being here
two other Winters and they were very
mild but I gotta be honest here this
winter is the mildest of all [__]
three I mean it's going to be April 1st
and you know I don't know how much snow
we're going to get in April you know I
don't know if this is like Colorado I
don't know and listen nobody knows
anymore you're getting tornadoes in
North Jersey you're getting tornadoes
and misses you know you're just getting
this temperature that nobody can explain
anymore I'm not listening guys I'm no
[__] fauci I don't know dick about
dick I'm just letting you know what I've
seen you know for 16 years and for years
after anytime I came here there was snow
this has been 60 degrees lately how the
[__] that we go from snow okay it's not
going to snow it stays at 38 40. guys I
put my winter jacket on
maybe five times
this winter it was all hooded
sweatshirts
you know a hooded sweatshirt here maybe
a t-shirt underneath guys I remember
growing up here and not being able to
walk having to have a hooded sweatshirt
and the wind would get in your [__]
ears your tears would your tears would
just freeze on your face you thought you
were gonna [__] die no
they've just been mild so I don't know
listen I was wrong I'm sorry every year
I predicted snow on my birthday [__] it
was 60 [__] degrees on my birthday
this year February 19th so
who the [__] knows what's going on
anymore you just get up do the best you
can do and tell them all to suck your
dick at least that's what I do I don't
care anymore had an interesting week
last week man uh I'm starting to come
out of my shell a little bit
I had to go up meet up I had to meet Lee
on Wednesday night up at Rudy's uh met
up with George and uh my My Brother
Carlos and Anthony I Felice on a cop on
a Cliffside and we had a nice little
[__] quick meal we had to run into
the City and do a spot
and uh we finished we had dinner I drove
him back to the [__] Ferry
and uh I made a quick U-turn and came
home no [__] must no fuss
Friday night I went to my daughter's
school play
holy [__]
holy [__] you know
it was an interesting week last week I
also booked a TV show which will get the
yeah she comes home Monday dad I booked
the [__] play we have rehearsal all
week and she's yeah she booked it Monday
she was like I'm gonna I think I'm gonna
audition for the school play because all
my friends are gonna do it what am I
gonna do all week just go to fat Joe's I
go audition she came home and she goes I
got one of the Pied Piper rolls like all
right knock yourself I didn't know what
the [__] expect guys you know yeah
you know me I don't know no but she
didn't play in L.A when it finished like
would you like to do it again and she
goes no this was fun doing I don't want
to do it again I said good no worries no
pressure from Uncle Joey I'm not Pistol
Pete's dad I ain't gonna [__] and I
don't give a [__] I'd rather you not act
and then last Monday she came home and
she goes I'm auditioning she got the
roll they had to rehearse every day till
five there was no extra school
activities and Friday night I said [__]
it let's go down there and see what this
is all about
oh little buddies were in it from the
fourth grade
uh I didn't even eat an edible you know
I didn't need a mushroom chocolate I
just went straight I just wanted to
[__] see what what you know what
happens I mean what happens you know
and it was mind-boggling guys it really
really was mind-boggling
to see her go up there like not scared
at all
when she made a mistake she laughed it
off
she made a mistake one time she caught
herself and she laughed at all she had
to sing
you know it was just good to see did I
call CBS afterwards no that I called
Disney no that I call [__] no
no it's on
we went out we got pizza afterward with
the parents and the kids and and this is
as as easy as pie the kids had a great
time I tell you all of them did good
there was one two three four five kids
that I [__] knew and all of them did
very [__] well
I mean it was just great to see you know
some of the parents were like are you
happy and I'm like
guys I just want it was great just to
see her up there [__] smiling you
know people like well you don't want to
interact
guys acting as a [__] grind you know
unless you walk in there throwing heat
from day one and everybody's standing
behind you grinding it acting is a
[__] grind man
listen I was in LA for 23 [__] years
and I think I've spoken about this [__]
how
in reality I would have made money as an
actor 3 out of 23 years I was there
my first year with Taco Bell
The Longest Yard here and there was
another year
and I did a couple TV shows that were
good years you know could I could I
drive a Bentley
was I gonna go to the [__]
dealership and buy a Maserati by no
means it was a good living
for somebody with a wife that's starting
out you know that doesn't isn't really
serious yeah it was a very decent living
but was it something that I was going to
knock him dead with no I did better with
comedy even when I was struggling with
comedy I did better with comedy but
there were years that you know guys I
always felt like I was everybody always
made money until I got that do you ever
feel like that guys like they get there
they play the guitar one song they get
20 grand I get there they want to give
me ten dollars you know this guy went
there two months ago they paid him 18
000 for the movie I got the same movie
and I got to sing and dance and wipe my
[__] on fire and they're gonna pay me
ten thousand less it was a story in my
life I'm not complaining I'm not
complaining at all but that's the way it
was you know the only time I made oh the
year of the pilot I made some money yeah
there you go but I wasn't gonna lie I
was gonna live off that money that year
but it was good a good amount from one
company
what was that about what's that
yeah no it was a CBS show and it just
recently popped up on IMDb maybe I spoke
about it
and maybe a year later I spoke about it
on the church and maybe a year later it
[__] popped up
and I was like Wow and I looked at who
it was on it and it was just four actors
so I think somebody made it after they
heard me and they put themselves up it
was only four people from Bronx County
you could check it on IMDb
no they gave me I'll tell you guys
because it was 1997. it didn't make it
it didn't make a dent in the debt that I
own
not even when you get a check and you
don't make a dent like you're like
do I pay any of the debt off do I
[__] because I can't pay it all off
with the [__] Dent I'm I own an
attorney I own a [__] uh I owe child
support I I think I owed everybody I
owed [__] at that point yeah I had
some friends I owed personal cash to you
know thank God they were in Loan Sharks
for nothing they would take little
payments I was [__] struggling oh my
God
at in 1996 I made ninety eight hundred
dollars
as a comedian living in Seattle
okay and before the whole year getting
50s and 100 bills
and that's
for the people who claimed who sent w9s
and [__] like that I'm not talking about
the People page 25 or 50. so all in all
you made like 11 000. so you figured I
made 11 000 no I made 11 and 96
maybe 12 and 97.
and maybe I think one year I made six
thousand miles in 95 I made six thousand
dollars and what makes it even the worst
that the year before that I made seventy
thousand dollars
being a sports betting guy and I made 60
in the month of December
I was within one [__] month and I
took a big chunk of that debt off but
there were still tons of debt so when I
got
the deal from Bronx County it was 25
000. but you got to remember guys I had
a move with that money
I had to get an apartment with that
money
I had to get settled with that money the
agents at that time I didn't have an
agent I closed out with an attorney who
charged me 250 flat
you know it was [__] great you know
so
they gave me 25 [__] Grand to move
which was great when you look at it on
paper but not [__] really and you
know but again Beggars can't be [__]
choosy right or wrong if you stay on a
[__] uh on a cold sidewalk eventually
you're gonna get a little bit of Sun so
I don't care eventually I was supposed
to get a paycheck like that
doc I never told you about Bronx County
I went and dug that high hopes for me
this is like a Hollywood Story like I
love Roseanne Barr I've always been a
fan of Roseanne Barr but I enjoy her
story better than anything in the world
how she was in the [__] original room
and Mitzi saw and throw her in the main
room and next you know The Tonight Show
soar that night and she got the Tonight
Show and her life change you know I wish
it was that happy I wish it was that
I wish everybody had that [__] story
you know you put your work in your
family struggled she had to like leave
her husband like she went to Denver LA
on her own without her family and she
[__] hit you know and that that's
that's a great story but that doesn't
happen to everybody
that doesn't happen to [__] everybody
what we talking about anyway Bronx
County so
when they came to me I was at Seattle it
was Thanksgiving
it was the Wednesday before Thanksgiving
and the club if you knew anything about
the Comedy Underground they gave you
Comedy Underground was a very strong and
unique Club
Monday Tuesday Wednesday
belonged to the comics
what that means is that they were
teaching you already in 1995 how to
promote your own nights so Monday night
was an open mic Tuesday night was an
open mic Wednesday was an in-house show
and Sunday was an In-N-Out show
I would do I would get a show with like
Tana Manu Josh Wolf
Brody and we would call it something the
gobble gobble show we'd sell tickets for
10 bucks if 50 people showed up we'd
chop up 500 bucks
you know we go to eat or something like
that it was no big [__] deal I walk
into this thing in Seattle I'm like
living on [__] nothing you know
trying to snort coke I'm living on an
office I was living in an office paying
125 a month and I was basically sleeping
on a towel
on the floor writing jokes I had a 1-800
number in there
I could call out and people could call
me on the 1-800 number don't ask and I
used to take shits out the window I
compete they didn't have a they had a
toilet no they had no bathroom and on
that thing so I had to pee out the
window and [__] out the window
so in the middle of night I would just
open the window
I was like on the fourth floor and there
wasn't and there wasn't a bathroom on
that floor
so I would have to open and oh and let's
go back to this there wasn't a window in
my office
so I would have to walk to the back you
know they had uh in the back of the
building it would be facing the ocean
and they would have those the sound as
you call it in Seattle and they would
have stairs fire escape I would have to
climb up on the fire escape take the
Cuban egg roll out and just [__] piss
from there and people be walking by and
from time to time I would have to take
my ass and [__] on the fire escape and I
would throw it away but every once in a
while a little third would slip in
between the [__] things and I would
hit somebody in the bottom or somebody
would I don't think I hit somebody
that that was rough so when they came to
like Wednesday night I could see if I
was in LA
or New York
and MTV comes up to you or
you know somebody comes up to your CBS
or NBC or Netflix that's one thing if
you're in a comedy club but if you're in
a metropolitan area like if you're in
New York or L.A you expect somebody from
time to time to go hey I'm with this
agency hey I'm with this [__]
Management Group it's just you know
that's what they do they go out at night
but when you're in a club in Seattle
the night before Thanksgiving when
people come up there they go hey man I
like that joke hey I'm from Jersey too
this little nerdy guy came up to me and
say hey can we have a word
and I'm like I had so many things going
on in my world at that time I had cops
looking for me people looking for me
prior to investigators looking for me so
I was like what the [__] is this what's
up and he's like listen
I have a pilot at CBS and I've been
looking for this character and I cannot
find them
you're the [__] character and I'm
like come on man
he's like you're the [__] character
I'm like
all right and I go where are you from
and he goes I'm from I'm from I live in
L.A but he goes I have a place since my
mother lives in Seattle I came up for
Thanksgiving we came out we were down
here eating dinner we came out to see a
comedy show you popped up it was like
maybe four or five years ago you popped
up and he goes tell me that you speak
Spanish and I'm like yeah and he goes oh
you're [__] perfect what they were
looking for was somebody Spanish who
didn't look Spanish
that's what they wanted they wanted
somebody Spanish who didn't look Spanish
so the guy gave me his card he took my
information which was a page number and
the phone number to The Comedy Club the
manager at the comedy club
and he said I'll be in touch
and I couldn't sleep I could not [__]
sleep man I couldn't have [__] sleep
for weeks I was so ecstatic that
somebody finally and he didn't hit me
back and I started to get worried I'm
like and I started to go on that funk
and all of a sudden out of the blue this
[__] hit me one day and he's
like hey
the pilots happening I need you in L.A
in January
what was this this is
December 13th of 1996.
he goes I need you in L.A
January latest
first week of February can you make it
and I'm like yeah
look I didn't have a [__] dime I
didn't know how I was going to get to La
I didn't know [__] all I knew was that
[__] they wanted me for a CBS pilot
and when he called December 12th or
whatever 13th he goes we want you but
you still got to come down
and and do a screen test
he didn't say he didn't call an audition
about two days later I'm doing comedy at
the
underground and a buddy of my rod long
comes up to me and he goes dog
you know
you think about Mike and I were talking
about you know things that go on on your
life you know sometimes
you don't you don't think your life is
working out like it should you know
but you look at things and you go wow no
matter what's going on now there was a
time when the universe came through for
me and it came through for garlic me a
lot of times regardless of my mother
praise and all that stupidity you could
sit here and look at all the negative
[__] but you do have to look at the
positive [__]
I had no [__] money I had nothing
you know and this comic said to me hey
man what are you doing
like two days from now like who asked
you that and you're like nothing
but he goes I gotta go to L.A to bring
art for an art show
wanna take a ride with me I'll cover
your gas
weed and whatever
he was one of my good friends in Seattle
this guy no matter what he was he always
had my back
I'm like are you [__] serious so I
called the [__] guy I go
I'm going to La I got a ride we'll be
there
Tuesday night and he goes perfect
can you do a spot at the Laugh Factory
Tuesday night for the people from the
show and I'm like if you I know they
won't give me a spot
but if you could [__] set it up for
me I'll definitely do it done he set up
a spot and then he goes you're gonna do
the Showcase Tuesday
your Wednesday you're going to
do a screen test
and then you're free to go and that's
Rod's plan was Tuesday he's going to
land we're going to relax go to dinner
and Wednesday we'll [__] do the art
show and Thursday we'll get in the car I
mean it couldn't it couldn't be any
[__] better guys you know
it's a Monday [__] motivation for you
it could it couldn't be any better just
when you think that things are not going
anywhere
we get back to Seattle I go on with my
life you know
now I gotta wait to hear from him again
he told me call me after the new year
so
I keep doing my comedy and one day I got
a call from uh Ron Reed another [__]
gentleman up in Seattle who took me Josh
a lot of us under his wing Brody
and he goes I have a spot for New Year's
it's opening up for Doug Stanhope he
asked if you were open before he gave it
away and I'm like [__] yeah I go see if
he needs a host see if he can use Josh
Wolf yeah he's open too [__] it so it
was me Josh and Stanhope now I'm
thinking about this as the money I'm
gonna use to go to LA
this is like [__] perfect like it
couldn't have happened at a better time
I was just gonna sit around and smoke
dope on [__] New Year's this is great
all right no [__] big no problem uh
New Year's comes
you know and I do the shows with
standoff and let's be honest I had
worked really hard
and you know you don't know when the the
fruits of your labor are going to pop up
the fruits of my labor popped up that
[__] uh that New Year's weekend I
think we added like three or four
[__] shows it was just phenomenal
Stanhope was a beast Stanhope will
always be a [__] beast and it'll
always be a beast in my eyes for what
I'm going to tell you now after the
weekend was over Stanhope stayed
you know we went to get drinks we went
to eat and one of the nights he goes
listen man
here's some cash like this is Doug
Stanhope he goes here's some cash
he goes they're going to send you a
check from whatever but I'm gonna give
you more you did really good and he goes
when are you moving to L.A and I'm like
tell me you didn't just ask me that and
he goes it's time for you to move to L.A
you're that good you're ready and I'm
like I don't think I'm ready yes you are
he's like I'm a d improv they're a bunch
of [__] humps every night you know
stand up he's like [__] them go down
there and do what you're doing here on
stage tear them the [__] up
I'm like okay you know I can't play and
then he says
the final hand of God because when you
come to La you got some place to stay
that's half the problem
when Comics want to go that way they're
like I don't know we don't know anybody
and we gotta sleep on a [__] basement
this guy just opened this home to me
he's like you got to play sustain man
forever long as you need I mean the
[__]
it couldn't have worked out any goddamn
better I mean you couldn't
put this together but as usual
don't let your character ruin your
[__] Destiny okay you're gonna
hear me say that I've been saying it for
10 [__] years I've been saying it
since the day I heard it which is about
16 years ago I heard that a little
before I quit Coke I heard somebody say
don't let your character ruin your
destiny
so here I am
I'm headed that way New Year's was great
we're gonna [__] do it
what do you think happens Uncle Joey
that Monday after that great new year I
got a letter in my house a summons
from a [__] assault in Seattle
that had happened
four or five months earlier and the
court had finally processed it and
finally caught it they were calling a
[__] probation hearing to revoke my
[__] probation
for me to do the rest of my time in
[__] County Jail whatever four months
of probation I had left they were
revoking my [__] sentence in the
middle of all this [__] I'm like God
damn it now I had to go to court like
the 16th of January just like the 4th of
January I got this news I just came back
I just [__] auditioned there was no
money yet on the table he just said come
down
I will call you a legit offer like by
the 10th or the 11th when can you be
down there
I said I don't know I'm putting it all
together now now I get this [__]
court case on the 16th and I'm like you
know staying hope gave me a place I got
my [__] money I got everything
everything I could have [__] wanted
I'm going my girlfriend at the time is
coming with me she's gonna drive
you know I got a place to stay with Doug
she's gonna put she's got a trailer so
even if we get stuck we got a trailer
we're not gonna be on the street if Doug
throws me out or changes his mind or
smells my fungi toenail he's not gonna
[__] panic and this is what I did and
I now I gotta go to [__] Court
back in Seattle but I I was I wasn't
even in La yet Seattle was not gonna let
me [__] go
but I had a cool probation officer him
and I I mean he was as cool as can be
for a probation officer
he was a dick but
I was behaving myself and he was cool
and I had spoken to him a lot about it I
went in there one day I got to talk to
you
and I go this is what they're trying to
do with him and he's like listen I had
to revoke it I got this [__] thing in
the mail
you had police contact you know and I
did it wasn't my fault at all it was a
fight I tried to get in the middle of it
to break it up also I'm getting held and
it was a it was enough cops report you
have to Pro we have to report it what it
wasn't his fault and I understood that
and he goes but
I have to go to court and I could just
talk in your bath
you know and just say that it was a
misunderstanding I'd come up late that
you have been doing well and I was at
that point I was pretty much out of the
[__] weeds
so he goes but it's still the judge's
decision and the D.A is [__] through
with you
you know at the time I had gotten
arrested five got arrested for a stolen
[__] car I had a bunch of arrests but
no convictions like they couldn't I
gotta I got arrested for uh uh [__]
jaywalking
I got a ticket to jaywalking didn't go
to court and that started a [__]
chain reaction and [__]
so she was like he was like the DA's a
little pissed at you or whatever you
know we'll talk
[__] then finally came the day I had
a
go in front of the judge and I was
[__] [__] pickles it was like the
16th and I'm like this [__]
this is my [__] biggest time in my
life the biggest opportunity I've had
since I got out of that [__] prison
five years I've been six years I've been
[__] scraping fighting eating [__]
Subway sandwiches the veggie and cheese
eat if I had money I'd eat the seafood
salad with the fake crab and the [__]
and the [__] Katrina shrimp before
Katrina you know this is just terrible
now I gotta go to [__] Court
because some guy got into a fight and I
got in the middle of it and [__] God
damn it and we get to court and sure
enough
the judges pissed the D.A is saying all
this [__] that they want to revoke it
that you know and finally my [__]
attorney who was she's not attorney no
more she got caught [__] in one of the
prisons
my attorney at the time
just said listen what if
what if Mr Diaz lives and doesn't come
back
and there was a silence in the courtroom
like we might be on to something man and
sure enough the judge called the D.A
over the D.A walked over they had their
little [__] meeting like they do on
Law and Order come here for a second
let's talk and the next thing you
[__] know the judge goes I think
we're going to do that
you leave Los Angeles promise never to
go come back
just leave us the [__] alone take your
criminal cuban ass to LA and just take a
anger management class
and that's it
yes there's still a warrant now after
the fact for the [__] but no it
wasn't a warrant for what I did because
there was no charge I didn't get charged
for the fist fight I got charged because
I broke it up and then then I got into a
fist fight not not really a fist fight
but we got into a a tugging match when
the cops [__] came they took
everybody's goddamn name down and my
name was on the police report that's the
way they say when you're on probation
don't go out at night like don't go to a
bar but Joey I'm just going to have a
beer I know but guess what's going to
happen there's going to be a fist fight
it's one of your [__] dummy friends
that had too much to drink and you went
to the wrong place for him you're gonna
get in to break it up because you're a
[__] Savage you're not gonna let some
[__] drunk guy pound on your friend
when he's hammered and when the cops
come you're gonna get handcuffed and
even if you didn't throw a [__] punch
your name's gonna be in the police
report
they're going to put your [__] name
down and somebody listen ninety percent
of the time they're not gonna catch it
but when you're the kiss of death like I
was at that time they're going to catch
it that's what I'm trying to [__] say
to you they're gonna catch this type of
[__] so
I was in shock when the judge said
okay that sounds like a good idea they
looked at me he goes did you hear that
you're never allowed to come back to the
state but you have to continue
the classes
are you them aware of it and keep them
the class will send them the information
they gave me all the paperwork for me to
take the anger management class and what
happened is simple I got the [__] L.A
it took me like 30 days to find the
class and then once I did find the
[__] class
once I did find the [__] class
I had to uh register wait to get on a
list they put me on the list everything
was great and it all worked it was 35 a
week
but on a Saturday morning at nine
o'clock
I do comedy guys I do stand up I tried
to get a Monday
I tried to get a [__] Wednesday I
tried and they were like nah you got to
start the Saturday program at nine
o'clock well it did for about three
weeks and then what do you think happens
you go to the store on a Friday night a
very innocent night you have a few
[__] cocktails you sit out there
talking to people until three in the
morning you go home The Exorcist is on
now you're up till 5 30 watching a
stupid movie trying to figure out
writing jokes and next thing you know
you wake up late
and you know they're going to close the
door at nine o'clock at you so
that's what happened that's why there
was a warrant on me from Seattle real
quick and now for a word for my
[__] sponsors Jack all right
you savage Savage I talked in the
beginning of the podcast listen this is
the biggest tournament in college
basketball and it's heating up and
there's still time to place bets with
DraftKings sports book listen
I don't know what you're thinking about
but we got player props team props odds
boost
same game parlays we got it all me I'm
looking at Connecticut and Danny Hurley
I gotta support my Jersey City boy like
I said we're bringing you parlays and
odds boost for the rest of the
tournament so do me a favor this week
check every day check your wrap every
[__] day the happy hour to see what
they got in store for you guys who don't
know DraftKings has a happy hour between
like three and nine eastern Time or six
and nine check it every day but first
you gotta download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app and sign up with code
Joey new customers can bet five dollars
on any pre-game money line and get 150
and bonus bets when their team wins
instantly only at DraftKings Sportsbook
with code Joey the official sports
betting partner of your Uncle Joey
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply she show notes for details now
back to the show we're back [__]
that's my [__] pilot story and that's
the beginning of it but I got the uh but
you went after that right yeah
guys I left
after that judge made the decision
I was out of that two days later there's
no reason to dick around I called the
[__] guy from La he told me to
I told him I was okay that I could come
I was coming
and he said that when I got there
uh after the read on Wednesday that I
had to sign a contract whatever the [__]
it was after that I went down he goes
that they were happy with me everything
was and I had to just come down and sign
a contract I was still asked I was still
scared to ask how much
like I I wouldn't even ask
like I was just petrified in my head I
had like a number like eight million you
know what I'm saying like this is going
to solve all my [__] problems I'm
gonna be twisting by the pool hanging
with [__] but uh it took a few days
and then right before I left he called
and he goes good news
I got you 25
000 I don't know if you're gonna stay
in Los Angeles that'll help with housing
uh you're gonna be on the set for maybe
10 days
and uh
that's it so you did it you shot it so
when I came I landed in L.A
on a Monday night I went to the Laugh
Factory on a Tuesday I went to The
Comedy Store that Monday and I think
that Wednesday I met with him
I had some attorney's office on Wilshire
Boulevard
I was like [__] sweating I was
petrified it was the first thing that
ever happened it took uh you know my
first year you're very excited because
you're like wow it took me
eight years to get on a TV show you know
wow you know wow you know and yeah there
was a lot of struggle and staying in
hotels and Rock Springs Wyoming and [__]
like that but wow it took [__] eight
years so that was very impressive
you know and then uh
we went to wardrobe we went through a
few things like that I didn't know what
to expect guys you know I didn't know
anything about that world I had never
taken an acting class or anything
hmm
and the next thing you know we get to
the set to rehearse and
everything was hunky dory everybody
likes Joey Joey likes everybody
until it was time for action and then
Joey didn't know what the [__] to do
talk I wasn't an actor I couldn't stand
in where you need to be and all that
kind of [__] I didn't know anything
never mind
dog I had lines I had like eight scenes
in this and this pilot maybe there's
it's a half hour no it was an hour pilot
I'm exaggerating maybe I had four scenes
but there were thick scenes when cops
would come into my bar and I would talk
to them I remember there was one bar one
scene where I'm sweeping outside and
uninforming comes talks to me because
I'm like the bartender of this neighbor
in the Bronx and I'm like the [__] uh
I was like the town crier you know like
uh if you ever see Starsky and Hutch
they had a rat
I wasn't a rat but I talked to this town
I talked to the neighborhood and I would
speak to the cops the cops were hanging
at my bar
I know you picked up Mike last week for
[__] DUI you're gonna cut him a break
for me you know [__] like that so I
remember there was one scene I was
outside talking to a junkie for a while
about his situation at home and I would
talk to a cop I was one of those guys
hey man can you talk to Mike the cop and
see if you get a deal for me I was one
of those guys I had that scene I had a
scene with like four cops and a and a
D.A
and then I had like a closing scene
where I'm talking to all the cops at
night before they leave you know
I think the first scene that they had me
do I didn't have any idea
if somebody sees this correct me if I'm
wrong was the scene at the bar at night
and it was like a laugh scene like
whatever
I had maybe three lines in the whole
thing it took it took like eight hours
to shoot
guys it was not good
and I for a minute there you could see
on my face I thought back on the feeling
it was not good it was not good walking
into a place very excited and realizing
that you don't have a [__] clue of
what you're doing
and everybody there thought I did have a
clue of what I was doing
so kind of made it the [__] worst you
know
so I like the first day was kind of
rough you know people were like looking
at me weird like
it was like the way we worked at La Brea
Leota during the [__] and many Saints in
Newark shoot God Rest his soul I'm not
trying to be cute or anything here uh
it was
it was just surreal that I didn't know
what I was doing and then we went the
second day
I had some type of rehearsal
and again
they were like oh I was lost I didn't
really get a grip on it to like the
third day
and even then I was lost I didn't know
what to do there was a uh
store where they sold
books on writing and acting and stand up
and you know Judy Carter's book they
stabbed everything Samuel French
Samuel French had two stores at the time
one in Hollywood and one in the valley
they had sold agent books anything you
needed to know about the entertainment
business
I remember running up there and buying
like three books on acting
like you know and they were already
telling me like you're gonna get a check
in like four days
so I'm like holy [__] if I come down
here
and they don't give me a check
it's gonna be [__] bad
so the more we rehearsed the next day I
noticed that my lines got taken away
from me
and the more we rehearsed I figured out
that they were taking me out of scenes
they were just taking me out of whole
scenes guys
you know when you're excited it destroys
your [__] destroys you like I went in
thinking I had four lines and now I'm
down to two I'm like [__]
you know with [__] like that guys that
just it just takes up when you don't
know what you do and it wasn't their
fault it wasn't my fault that we didn't
know we didn't know he thought I had he
never asked it's not like he said to me
did you go to Juilliard yeah I didn't go
to [__] Juilliard I went to the
school of [__] deli's that's where
you tell stories and [__] like that I
didn't know the [__] Juilliard so
well no they then then I gotta check and
I'm like they didn't give me that they
didn't give me the whole check they gave
me like a half a payment like 12.50 like
12 000 I was like wow holy [__]
but the most depressing day was the day
we actually started shooting the pilot
I got there they had like a mini table
read
and I was down I started off the whole
shoot with maybe 20 lines and now I was
down to two
guys I was never ever so embarrassed
in all of my life
and I remember that I signed with a
manager at that point
and
like I was like you gotta really find
out what's going on
he called back one day he's like they
like it but they they just going to see
it if the show gets picked up
thank you
then about two months later he called me
and he goes nah you're all in
you're fine it looks like CBS is gonna
announce the show in May
they're going to keep you as the
bartender they needed Spanish people
it's like anything else you need like a
grant from [__] the Cesar Chavez
organization or some [__] I don't know
why they kept me I don't even know if
it's true all I know is I was [__]
you know thank God I'm not an idiot
buy a house on credit or
you know start smoking cigars and [__]
because CBS have given
I forget what his [__] name is and it
tortures me
for you guys who know The Sopranos the
guy who played the doctor in the prison
with Johnny sack
he played like the orderly that guy's a
big time guy was in a bunch of movies
he's also a big time director
not Sydney lumet maybe one of Sydney
Sydney Pollock
this was Sidney Pollock's Bronx County
Sydney Palmer CBS had given Sydney
pollock a million dollars so we're like
[__] somebody gives me a million dollars
it's on right in any other world
somebody gives you a million dollars
you're [__] working for that million
dollars
I was in Miami it was right after my
apartment got towed
I was [__] miserable I had no clothes
I was getting 350 a week for hosting and
I would have to spend 200 of it on
clothes from all you know I had to start
from sneakers socks I would just go to
[__] Old Navy every day and buy a
pair of jeans for five dollars
and on that I'm like this is just you
know now thank God I had to they they
put me in a condo in Miami and I'm like
this is all going to be till that pilot
gets picked up because the 25 000 was
for the pilot shoot now they'd have to
decide how much I was gonna make every
week
and at the end or whatever I mean it was
called moving fast and I was [__] all
in on this [__]
and I remember I was in Miami and I was
like [__] I only got two more weeks
until I find out
I was opening up for Robert Schimmel in
Miami God bless his soul
I was supposed to open up for Rob
Schimmel
he was working Friday and Saturday but
there was some [__] guy that it was
the first reality show like how did
David millionaire and he won he was a
stand-up comic so he was popular again
they put him on the road and schimel
didn't like that they took away his
[__] uh
his uh they took away his Thursday so he
canceled and it was the first week I had
a headline with a gun to my head
like I didn't have the time to headline
they were like Joey you got 40 minutes
yeah they're like you're [__] had
London this week I'm like God damn at
least I was making some money but I got
the call that Friday at the pilot didn't
get picked up and I was [__] crack
but thank God I didn't spend the check
before I [__] had it but again even
then that was 1997.
going into 98
I had him booked uh
basketball yet and I had I think I did
book The Taco Bell commercial so between
the Taco Bell commercial and
the CBS show
I'm lying to you guys it was a really
good year I forgot about that Taco Bell
commercial that was a very good year and
I remember getting an insurance card
like I was getting all this [__] in the
mail
and I was like wow if this is what I
make in one year I'm gonna have a good
career if I could book a commercial and
One Pilot every year I'm gonna [__]
have a great career making money-wise
I booked five Pilots after that I made
[__] nothing
and I booked
I think four more commercials after that
they didn't pay me a third of what those
jobs paid me like you think inflation's
going up what they're paying is also
[__] going down so this week I start
the week off my daughter getting that
audition and Monday I forgotten that I
had an audition
listen I had an audition for a [__]
popular show
it shoots in New York City I was very
happy with it I've shot it before
I put the audition on tape I must be
back because I shot the [__] in
two takes I had that [__] you know what
I'm saying they're like you're good to
go but they called on Thursday and
they're like hey man can you uh
you booked it congratulations
the first offer they made me first off I
didn't know what I was reading for I
didn't know whether it was a guest star
or co-star listen guys I don't give a
[__] I'm just happy that they offered me
something and they let me do a [__]
audition that's all I'm I'm grateful for
that
thank you
I put the audition on tape boom I got
the call Thursday morning they call it
905. I was telling Mike
and they go hey we offered it to you
bye-bye congratulations we'll call you
more with production like okay and right
away my wife called him she goes I saw
the offer
are they [__] serious and I'm like
yeah
I go I won't do it for that I go it's
not worth it because I got to pay
commissions on that drive do all this
[__] but
I'm trying to bump them up you know my
wife is like wow that was low I mean
it's it's [__] low guys real [__]
low
and you know I called back my agent the
guy who was helping me for that these
particular gigs and he goes yeah I'll
get you some more money he got me some
more money
still
it wasn't
a [__] third of what I had gotten in
99 2000 when I was doing co-stars in the
early 2000s and then I started booking
guest stars there was still a little
money left again when I started booking
guest stars people were making 15 grand
when I started booking them I was making
five grand what happened to the 10 grand
there but you know other guys and you
don't sweat it you're just fortunate
enough to be there
so
they'll come back with the dough blah
blah blah and then like listen uh it
shoots Monday morning and I exactly know
what that means it's Thursday which
means I need to go into the [__] City
on Friday
now my daughter's got to play plus I'm
shooting PRP in my knee
I don't think this is going to work on
[__] Friday you know the girls got to
play at seven I don't want to be getting
through their [__] rushed up from the
Jersey Turnpike and the parkway it's a
[__] drag to drive on that [__]
all right
they go no worries
we'll get in Friday for wardrobe but
we'll get here as early as possible and
I tried to work with them myself try to
cancel the doctor's appointment
bro these [__] called back
Thursday night at 11 o'clock at night
to tell me no we'll see you tomorrow at
three
and I'm like you know what man you know
me guys I love to work I'm a modest guy
but guess what I'm not going in there at
three on a Friday just not doing it I
don't know where I'm going I have no
idea it's Friday Friday and it's gonna
[__] rain if there's an accident on
that Turnpike I'm gonna have to sit that
to my escrow's roots
I'm not it's not worth it to me anymore
you know and I tell them the truth I'm
not doing it they're like okay we could
do the Wardrobe on [__] Monday
and you need to take a covert test you
need to come in here on Sunday
I'm not doing that either
listen kovid is a is dead Elvis is dead
and I don't feel so good myself if you
get coven now you even tell somebody
you're a [__] idiot just go along
with your wife nobody's dying anymore
that's it it's over you know and then
they started with the [__] oh we need
a covet card listen it's last I checked
Kyrie Irving is playing
lest I checked Kyrie Irving is playing
again that's it what's with the [__]
covet card you know enough with this
[__] already it's over
okay we can take the covet test Monday
when you get there nah they call back
Friday night at 11. you need to take it
what's the nearest coven testing
facility to your house
CVS Maybe
let's do a CVS right down the corner you
know
Gwen did that Saturday it's a 24-hour
turnaround the 48 hours they will hit me
back way before the 24 hour mark to
[__] find out the results I'm like
what did they call CVS get to the bottom
of this production is waiting no they're
not
no they're not
this is just you guys you know you learn
so much over the years and again I quote
that Bill Hicks thing constantly it's
not that you're lazy it's not that Pop
makes you lazy is that what you're
thinking about doing isn't worth it you
think about it's not worth it when I'm
about to go down there and sweep and
pick up the broom and talk to that boss
and it's the same with me I'm not lazy
I'm not saying that I smoke dope all day
what I'm saying is that as you get older
you're like
I want to do it but
it's not worth it like that after the
commissions
the Jersey tax the New York tax and I
sit here and think about young actors
I don't think about me you think I give
a [__] about me I think about people who
actually go to NYU
people actually go to UCLA or USC
and do all these great acting things and
they come out into the world they're 22
years old you know how hard it is to
convince your [__] parents that you
want to be a [__] goddamn actor
do you know how hard it is for any
[__] kid to have to go up to their
parents and go hey
I I want to be a [__] actor and
you're like well we had plans for you we
wanted you to be a [__] slobalist or
whatever the [__] I'm underwater surgeon
you know I'm just making [__] up here
but it's like
how can you justify it
you got to go to acting class you got a
[__] starve then you get shot by Alec
Baldwin you know they never [__] I
mean what the [__] and I love guys I
[__] I'm a movie buff I do a review
on patreon I love all this [__] I watch
two to three [__] movies a week that
you wouldn't even think of while
watching I'm such a [__] [__]
movie buff I love all this [__] I love
the process of acting I love shooting
but guys at one point you know I'm
starting to look at it now like how
desperate I was
to succeed
because I would have done I would have
jumped all those hoops and that the more
you do it I told you guys years ago that
there came a time I didn't like working
no more I love booking a job I love
going in there and booking the audition
and telling everybody suck my
[__] dick Jack I'm a dirty
stand-up comic but I'll always comedy
and with all this acting
and I'm making a [__] living listen I
enjoy it I love it
it's like [__] uh you know being I
got an offer for a theater play a couple
weeks ago
guys I would love to be in [__]
theater like a long-running show in
Manhattan like
but they taught you the rehearsals I
don't have [__] eight hours a day to
rehearse after we have it we move the
[__] on after the show's going and
you're rehearsing no they taught you and
it's like after a while
it's like hurry up
what's the expression for people in
Hollywood hurry up to sit like they have
a joke that they do
to carry up this city here for [__]
eight hours and then we'll get to you
and it's like I'm over it I respect
people and I respect your wishes and I
respect your production
but you know what man
I don't know what happened to it
you know I was in L.A I was very happy I
wasn't even acting a kid who came from
an acting background or anything I don't
know anything about [__] acting I'm
like poorly and Good Fellas I don't know
anything about restaurants I go to the I
go to the restaurant I order food I'm
the same way I don't know anything about
[__]
I go to the movie theater I get [__]
Snickers and I sit there and I love
yesterday I got a little Reese's penis
[__] tremendous when I went to see
John week those little Reese's Pieces oh
they're [__] tremendous I split a bag
with my daughter but
you know I was hoping that Jesus I
needed listen I needed a certain amount
to get insurance
and this didn't even come close to it
but I didn't care
it'd be nice to work walk around New
York City on Monday shoot maybe get a
butted [__] bagel meet some new
people it's not about the [__] money
but at the same time you got to pay your
bills
you gotta [__] pay rent you know you
got to do [__]
so I'm happy that Mercy did a [__]
play I'm jumping up and down about it
but it's not I hope she doesn't get into
it listen God bless her God bless him
she wants to try this [__] God bless him
they want to try basketball but I tell
you what for acting stand up
all these things that we like doing the
Highlight doing you know it's
you could do all these things as a hobby
you know acting is a great hobby I told
everybody I [__] knew over and over
and over again if you ever go to La if
you ever decide to go to Los Angeles for
a job I don't care if you're selling
[__] cemetery plots
I don't give a [__] what you're doing in
L.A you have to go transfer that for a
job and you're close to the Hollywood
area
do me a favor
go to a [__] commercial agent and
apply listen commercials they'll take
you in a [__] New York minute uh
for a commercial an agent like if you go
in and go I want to be an actor I need
an agent I'll go take a [__] hike but
if you go in and I want to be
commercials whether you're missing
fingers whether you have an eye whether
you have a pogo stick for a leg
don't [__] sign you while you're
there you might as well audition for
commercials because you never know you
might make six figures so take a chance
[__] Columbus did [__] and
that's the Monday podcast on March 27
2023. I love your [__] stay black
and now for a word for my [__]
sponsors
all right it's a beautiful Monday
morning I want to thank DraftKings and
Bluetooth for sponsoring the show as
usual today's episode was sponsored by
Bluetooth and it's true what they say
confidence can make up for a multitude
of sentence so when it's time to sling
dick blue shoe is there for you
Bluetooth is an online service that
delivers Ed slash dead dick medication
to your door it's got the same active
ingredients as Viagra Cialis Levitra at
a fraction of the course I love it
you're gonna get it for free and it
comes in a little personal little pouch
you put in your wallet and when you bump
into a freak boom there you are
Bluetooth will make sure you're prepared
to take that monkey down Anytime
Anyplace blue suit blue shoe wants to
help you have better sex okay discover
your options at bluetooth.com chew it
and do it and they got a special deal
for Uncle Joey's listeners you ready I'm
gonna give you a Bluetooth for free on a
beautiful Monday morning you're like
Joey what's free free use promo code
Joey at checkout pay five dollars for
shipping and that's it on a beautiful
Monday that's bluetooth.com promo code
Joey to receive your first month free
I'll see you [__] next Monday
morning Tip Top Magoo have a great week
foreign
[Music]